many 18th and 19th century romantic
poets poets or believers in rebellion
against social conventions
express strong emotion and the power of
imagination so
spider sense is already sensing
something a little bit off so we're
talking about many 18th and 19th century
romantic poets so we're talking about
poets so the poets were believers in
rebellion against social
conventions
and express strong emotions so
once again this is strange because the
first part of this we're listing the
things that they did so
the poets were believers in rebellion
against social conventions
and
they expressed strong emotions or
were believers in rebellion against
social conventions express strong
emotions so it's what's really troubling
here why this feels off is that this
the were believers
were
this is in the past
this is in the past right over here
while
while express
express right over here this is in the
present
this is in the present so the verb tense
is off you know
and we're definitely talking about stuff
in the past 18th and 19th century
romantic poets so we're going to want to
all of these statements about them
should be in the past so it should be
we're believers in rebellion against
social conventions expressed strong
emotions and the power and or i guess
express strong emotions and the power of
imagination so even this is a little bit
strange let's just read the different
choices so we don't like it as is so
let's rule out a that's always it
unchanged as the underlined the
underlying part unchanged so let's look
at the other choices
many 18th and 19th century romantic
poets
are believers well this is in the
present but clearly we're talking about
things that happened in the past 18th
and 19th century poets so we're going to
rule this out we don't like this
happening in the present
many 18th and 19th century romantic
poets who believed in rebellion against
social conventions
express strong emotions so once again
we're keeping this part over here this
is in the present express it should be
expressed it should be in the past tense
we're talking about 18th and 19th
century poets we'll rule that one out
many 18th and 19th century romantic
poets believed in rebellion against
social conventions
to express strong emotions
and the power of imagination
and the power of imagination so
this is
this is strange because they didn't
believe in rebellion
against social conventions so that they
could express strong emotions
it was so this is just the meaning here
just seems off so i i hope that this one
reads a lot better
many 18th and 19th century romantic
poets believed in rebellion against
social convention so far so good past
tense the expression of strong emotions
and the power of imaginations so this is
really neat because
what did they what did the poets believe
in
they believed in and once again it's
past tense so that's good and they
believed in three things it's very
clearly articulated they believed in
rebellion against social conventions
that's the first thing they believed in
the second thing they believed in is the
expression of strong emotions and then
the third thing that they believed in
was the power of imagination so this
believed this past tense this action of
believing in the past this applies to
these three clauses they believed in
rebellion against social conventions the
expression of strong emotions and the
power of the imagination what what was
really kind of bothering me up here in
the original one is beyond this verb
tense they were believers and then they
expressed strong emotion
and then the power of imagination is
this
or is this something they're expressing
it kind of you know
if if all of these were things that they
were expressing they they should have
put the expressed out front so this was
a you know the for several reasons this
first one was very strangely formed but
we really like we really like e